about half of the people in Somalia
depend on humanitarian Aid following
Decades of Civil War and devastating
droughts this woman is one of them
when there is food Aid distribution they
come with government forces to the camps
they also give some cash to the soldiers
when the soldiers leave the camp owners
turn around on you and take the food you
were given you miss the food and instead
get four dollars and if you make noise
you lose the four dollars
the United Nations has investigated
reports of theft it concluded that
landowners local authorities members of
the security forces and humanitarian
workers were all involved in stealing
Aid
the European union says it's temporarily
suspended Aid as it awaits clarification
successive Somali governments have been
plagued by corruption scandals the
government now said that Aid
distribution needs more transparency and
fewer layers of subcontractors despite
the enormous generosity of the
International Community and the donors
to Somalia that almost all Aid coming to
Somalia
bypasses the government system and and
therefore the government often does not
have a direct
um link when it comes to Aid management
most somalis are herders millions of
animals have died
others are farmers who've had to leave
their land
nearly four million people are displaced
because of drought and conflict many of
them live in camps
humanitarian Aid is one of only a few
ways to survive
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera